uh comeback trail when's that coming out
the comeback trail
is such a good movie and you got to see
the trailer um it's on
youtube um i have a legitimately large
part in this movie i couldn't believe it
myself but it's me and de niro
and morgan freeman again and um
tommy lee jones and um and emile hirsch
really good i don't know because like so
many movies it was gonna come out this
this fall and got pushed to to next year
it looks so
funny oh my god you look so funny that
character and you're working with the
nero side by side was that just
i mean honestly that's the question
you're going to hear for the rest of how
was it like working with daenerys
was it was he just was he just kind of
quiet like are you doing sorry
very quiet i think the first thing i was
surprised about and a lot of people
surprised that he's very quiet
um when he's not between you know not
between action and cut he's
the nero we all know and if it's intense
he's intense and if it's funny he's
being crazy and he's
i mean it's a joy to watch it's like if
you love actors it's like having a
front row seated one of the best of all
time but then you call
they call cut and he kind of quietly
goes back to his chair and
you know and i i it was my mit we were
in albuquerque shooting it and it was my
mission that he was going to become my
friend so little by little
it's like it's like um you know someone
in the
in the wild befriending like a wolf like
dancing with wolves
i was like de niro will be my wolf i am
going to
little by little i'm going to be this
man's friend whether he likes or not so
when you
yeah go ahead go ahead he's just shy i
mean i think he's a shy person and of
course
because of who he is everybody in the
world wants to talk to him and he kind
of
um keeps to himself and then but but but
little by little we bonded and and
became friendly and
now we we text and you text with robert
de niro
we do in flack flow and i went to dinner
at his house uh which was
just epic and um and yeah i uh we sat in
his massage chair we both got
massages from deniro's massage chair
wait a minute so he'll sit there and go
oh you gotta think take a look at this
massage shack are you gonna be there sit
down no it's great
yeah yeah the squid he's really good in
the movie by the way i mean the movie
it's frustrating because i i haven't
really got an opportunity like this
in that so much of my career has been
um the tv show and then the stuff i
created
and then a handful of other things but
but i never gotten an opportunity
to go toe-to-toe with someone like de
niro
in a way that i get to in this movie i
mean i'm really
i'm his nephew and he we're we're we're
b-list movie producers in the 70s you've
got to i mean i can't wait to see
a minute it's really funny if you watch
the trailer you'll crack up so funny
it's such a crowd pleaser and de niro's
never been so funny since
you know this it was written by george
gallo who wrote
midnight run so it's that style of movie
but um
but anyway it was just a disappointment
because this was a huge opportunity for
me because
i want to show people
um you know that i can
i don't know the other things other than
what they know me for and this was this
was a real chance to do that
you know it's it's tough because you
know you got it
you know like you have to it's not it
you call it ego whatever it is that's
like you're doing this
for a reason you're doing we're in this
business because we think we belong
you hope you belong and you know you get
opportunities and you succeed with those
opportunities and things become
successful
some things don't but then you sometimes
go well i never really got to do that
i never and you just always are waiting
for more and more and it's it's an
insatiable like i guess
insatiable thirst of just you you don't
the wanting to prove yourself doesn't
end it's always you want to prove
yourself not only to other people but
i know i can do this but you want to
prove to yourself you want to prove to
everybody like look i [ __ ] belong i'm
with deniro
and i'm hanging with them and i'm i'm
i'm i should be here
and again it's so you know what we do
when you're an actor like it's so rare
that
you're ever doing it you know if you're
a painter you can paint all day
i get if you're a musician you can write
all day an
actor it's like you're waiting for the
opportunity to finally come you audition
and you hustle and you memorize
i mean even when you're not a struggling
actor anymore we're still
you're still hustling and trying to get
an exciting opportunity